this episode of the pain game podcast is
sponsored by new a lot of you they've
been passing comment on my way my figure
so to speak oh my god jody you used to
be super fat and now you're not as fat
well i'm not going to like you a lot of
it's been exercised but there's also a
special program that's also been helping
and the name of it is noon noom is a
program which helps me understand how my
mind works and every day i do these
little courses that they've got on the
program which take no more than five to
ten minutes and they help you get your
mind right
to achieve your goals for the rest of
the day and as it happens i'm going to
do one right now so you just click on
the course it tells you a little bit
about what you're going to be doing and
then you just answer the questions fun
eating is when you eat foods that give
you pleasure and we all know i do a
little too much of that don't store
meeting is when you eat even if you're
not hungry and you feel like you can't
stop this one's me yeah yeah
they've done me they've done me there
i'm a storm eater yes
can't stop for no reason try to avoid
labeling foods as good and bad rework it
reprogram yourself they've also got
other things like a coach that you can
talk to get advice off of i didn't ask
for a woman uh would have been fine to
be a man no problem either way
information which is what i'm here for
so you've seen how easy it is why not
try it yourself if you're trying to
better yourself go to noom.com jody or
the link in the description below you
can click on that and when you do
there's a 30 second quiz to get you
started so thanks to noom for sponsoring
this episode
but now
enjoy the podcast
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fight this was designed for me to do
what
[Music]
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a month like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm the best
fighter in the world i'm the most brutal
and efficient
uh welcome back to
the pain game podcast today i'm joined
by
eddie hearn must be one of the hardest
working men i know actually well yeah i
suppose i mean um
you know somewhere else
i don't know what else i do with myself
do you know what i mean like life is
people say to me don't you ever switch
off don't you ever
and then sadly someone said to me the
other day what else did you do what else
do you like to do outside of work i was
like oh loads of things i said well like
what i said um
i like to watch boxing
i like i like to go to fights
i like to go to a gym
you and dana white are the like people
who i'd love to live their lives like
because you get all of the greatness of
being the ringside and all of the fun
and getting involved but you don't get
punched in the face it's absolutely
fantastic
yeah you know you do have to you do have
to put up with uh you know
the the fans which is good and bad
sometimes as well but
yeah
but it's a it's a drug you know i don't
do drugs so this is my drug really um
the business and the sport and and
everything else that we do at metro
whether it's darts whether it's snooker
you know they're all big passions of
ours but nothing lights me up like
boxing and um i've been around it all my
life and and i love it
it's the worst
uh sport in the world sometimes the
worst business in the world you know
this week we lost a billion white fight
with injury and then you just fancy just
going into a room and curling up and
crying and just saying why do i bother
you know why do i bother and then you
have to roll your sleeves up and crack
on
i've reconnected with one of my old
mates from uh who i grew up with who was
a podium squad boxer for team gb his
name is lawrence osweck he actually
fought on a newcastle show and
such a great talent and such a hard work
and loud but yet sometimes it just
doesn't happen for for whatever reason
where you get put on uh hold through uh
the lockdowns and it's a struggle so
the thing i've been learning is
sometimes the best
guys who have all this talent it
you have to have luck as well you have
to have injury free time
it's so difficult to make it to the top
and i guess um you know with the dillian
situation
uh how how frustrating is it to put all
that effort in and then have everyone
calling you
yeah i mean it's like um
firstly on the lawrence suseki stuff
he's actually boxed on a couple of our
shows he's a good fighter
i think boxing is probably one of the
most um
brutal sports outside of the ring in
terms of
making it getting that opportunity
getting that um
you know that crack that one chance that
can change your career and change your
life that comes
in
all kinds of different spaces in life
you know some people are the brightest
people in the world
and
never get an opportunity to be
financially successful or actually
achieve their own version of success
that comes through luck that comes from
hustle that comes from being streetwise
being common sense a lot of the time it
comes from hard work and having a
passion for what you do i truly believe
that you know and some people everyone's
got their different struggles haven't
they you know and like for me
i was blessed
with
a a really good upbringing you know my
dad made monies from a council estate in
in east london made money i got i got
given a head start really
you know it doesn't mean that i can take
it to where i've taken it to
you know a lot of people who get those
kind of opportunities quite frankly [__]
it all up
do you know what i mean
but
but everyone's got different different
chances and and people like lawrence and
those guys they've got to
they're they're really they haven't been
blessed necessarily with the opportunity
but when they get the opportunity
they've got to take it with both hands
and the special ones
will shine
but those special ones by the way are
0.0001
i'm talking about
tyson fury anthony joshua canelo alvarez
they're the ones where you will watch
him and go
wow as soon as you say wow
you're in
right you're locked in the more i learn
about boxing uh through people like
vidal who's a friend of mine as well the
more i realize
[__] hell it's it's one of the
hardest jobs in the world and uh i can't
imagine how hard it is for some of them
because the pressure
to make enough money and i i mean i was
chatting to tony bellew and uh and he
said
you know mushroom
pay every single fighter who's ever
fought on a card for theirs and as much
as that shouldn't be something unusual
in boxing it is and then talking to
lawrence i realized how often he'd
fought for zero you know literally just
selling enough tickets to pay for the
guys fighting and just it is it is hard
and you know i've just had a little
memory come back to me that i haven't
spoken to you about since it happened
but um you know you've got situations
that you have to deal with where derek
chazora's on stage with you basically
saying i want more [__] money
and you know what because
it's weird but derek chazora isn't
necessarily the best uh
you know fighter in the world but he's
probably the most intimidating and uh
you know like there's every chance that
this could just go tits on stage
what is it like dealing with boxers on a
business level
you know because people don't mess with
money especially boxers i think i'm
lucky enough where you know as i often
get reminded that i was brought up with
a silver spoon in my mouth
i still come from a working class
background
where i spent all my early years hanging
around
with tough people
with with bad people with you know with
and the one thing that i've got i've i'm
streetwise
right i know i have common sense i can
adapt to different situations and
personalities
you know if you put me in front of a
corporate bank it's no problem for me if
you put me in front of a guy that wants
to rip my head off
i've been there and i've seen that as
well now when it's derek chizora that
does pose a little bit of a different
element to that how did you handle that
after that after that finish because
we've seen basically adam smith [__]
himself you sort of
you sort of laughed a little bit but
stayed calm about it yeah um what
happens when you get off stage how do
you talk a lot fronting things up in
life is always the best way to deal with
things so
whether you've got a problem or whether
you need to face adversity or whether
someone's confronting you like that the
best thing to do is to front things up
you know and we had we had a press
conference here today with dillian wyatt
and i said to him we need to go and do a
press comment oh you know i'm pissed off
no no we got a front up
to the media to the public
and we've got to talk to him about it
you know there's no point
putting a press release out or going
quiet on it we've got nothing to hire
let's go and talk so we're going to talk
with trezora you just have to look him
in the eye and tell him
you know what i mean now it doesn't
always work like that and it doesn't
always go very well um but people like
chizzora will respect you more if you
front things up and you give him a
straight answer
i've lost count of the amount of time
that i've given to zora more money once
we've agreed a deal i've given him a
watch i've given him i don't know loads
loads of different stuff um to get him
in the fight when you negotiate with
some people like derek gizora
um he's got a lot better now because
actually his negotiations got a lot
better and he rinses us at stage one
rather than stage two and three
but in the early days i would almost
negotiate with derek gizora just holding
just a little bit back because i know
he's going to be back for more do i mean
so i used to be very scared of derek
gizora
now i'm just a little bit scared of him
honestly there's very few people who who
make me feel the way chazora does i've
been in his company before and you think
it's like being with a lion or a tiger
in it you're like you don't know what
the [__] could happen but that that's
the problem yeah that you've just you've
just hit the nail on the head right
which is you could be and they're the
most dangerous people
right you know the one where you're
having a great laugh or you just say one
thing you might not have deemed it to be
anything offensive yeah and it's just
what do you mean he's like joe pesci and
[__] goodfellas and he's [__] but
a massive version
yeah you could you could just be having
a conversation having a great chat and
you say
that spaghetti is great in that
restaurant and he says what do you mean
and it's like
the spaghetti is great in the restaurant
yeah
why are you talking about spaghetti it's
like oh man
i've i've heard i have second hand where
people he's been in restaurants it's
funny you should mention that and like
they they've asked them sparkling or
still and he's like well of course i
want still
you know
he's actually though he's actually a
really nice guy yeah
i'm sure
just don't make sure he doesn't say this
interview um
that's why i said he's a nice guy
um but yeah i think it was a very good
pr move during the white uh press
conference because
you know if if you put out a statement
and white doesn't show his face
it just looks like he's lying you know
what i mean because he has so much to
gain from not taking the wall in fight
which was a risky fight for minimal gain
versus
you know potentially beating tyson fury
if he could pull it off um so you know
you advise them right there um what is
the injury
the injury is his shoulder which he you
know he has had a shoulder injury before
he had an operation on shoulder as well
um basically
the news about tyson fury broke about
four weeks ago that he was going to be
mandated to fight him
i have to be honest at the time i
thought to myself
jesus that makes the volume fight even
higher stakes we sat down with dillian
he said look i haven't boxed since march
i have to fight i beat this guy
99 times out of 100 in my opinion
i'm you know no problem going ahead with
a fight we moved forward about two weeks
ago i actually got a text from one of my
guys who's sparring with him i said
how's sparring going and he said oh we
haven't sparred for two days dillian's
uh his shoulder i didn't know about this
this was two weeks ago so then i phoned
the team i said look nothing major he's
just had an eagle inspiring he's not
going to spa for a couple of days he
returned to sparring did one on a
saturday did one on the monday on the
monday out to stop after eight rounds
went for an mri doc says you can't fight
you know you you at the moment you have
a problem with your shoulder if you go
on and make this bad you're going to
need an operation on your shoulder
you're going to be back to square one
you could be out for over a year
and and yes you're you are right
tough fight against walling
fury
you know uh on the horizon as well
if you can't if your arm's not right and
you can't do the 12 rounds against the
championship fire you can't fight and
the doctor said to him you can't fight
and he was devastated and as i go back
to
you don't get paid if you don't fight
right i know he's going to make good
money to fight fury in march or april
whatever that is there is no benefit to
not fight him for a year in fact it's
going to give him less chance to beat
tyson fury you know he lost a big payday
to fight otto wilding as well and i have
to be honest as well
he's a tough [__] dylan white
you don't mess around with me i mean he
don't pull out a fire
and he knew
the stick that was going to come with it
and that's why he actually didn't even
want to pull out the fight but the
doctor said to him you can't go on so
a shoulder injury i would say four weeks
or so of rehab no operation needed but
has to be a hundred percent for any
quite titan fury
i seen white said at the press
conference i think people are giving me
stick because of you
um
and a lot of there's been a few comments
uh i've seen in interviews where people
said what about when you said this about
de bois what about when you said this
you feel a bit um
i don't know how to phrase this
sorry for dillian that something that
you've said has given people less
sympathy to him
yeah maybe i mean i do feel like um
the fighters that are with us
who probably get more stick absolutely
than the fighters that are just with
some like or or or don't even have
because
you know
although
i'm i'm popular i'm unpopular whatever i
am but i also do about a million
interviews a day so it's very easy to
pull up something like coogan said to me
well you said that you wanted to see a
scan from daniel dubois i said i didn't
say that i said i haven't seen a scan
from daniel dubois so i can't comment on
his injury you know but it's like
you know you get to a situation with
come on later with the zone you know and
pay-per-view and stuff like that that
well you said four years ago
that blah blah blah well things change
markets change decisions change models
change businesses change sports yeah so
many things change and i think if dylan
white didn't have a big profile and
wasn't with matrum
then he probably would have got left
stick
but also
mainly because of the fact that no one
would have given up up because they
would have known who he was anyway
so that's the benefit of being with us
and he's done a great job himself we've
done a great job as a team
to move forward and give him a big
profile but unfortunately it comes with
a territory when you're allowed now
and a big mouth promoter
people are going to
call you up on things all the time and
that just comes with a territory
the the strange thing for me is is is
you know when i read these comments and
you know youtube comments are bollocks
at the best of times but
it it's it's bizarre that
we as boxing fans need you to deliver
the best that you can deliver
and and the the better you do the better
our entertainment is and yet it feels
like i don't know how what a percentage
is but there's a group of them a large
group that want you to fail for whatever
reason oh badly
why does that how does that make you
feel
because you're trying to deliver
entertainment for them and make them
happy and yet they want you to fail
i perform best
when
you know
at school
i had a real problem with authority
right i was i was probably a bit of a
spoiled kid because i was traveling
around the world
with eubank and naz
bruno
and lennox lewis and you know
and then i'd go back to school on a
monday and i'd have this teacher that i
had no respect for
telling me what to do
and i'd think i've just been in madison
square gardens
what am i going to listen to
i look back and i cringe i hate that
because respect is the thing that i try
and instill in my kids the most out of
anything right
but i perform best
when people
give me responsibility
support me
um
and encourage me
to be honest with you so
the greatest feeling i have is when
fight fans
do give me a pat on the shoulder i don't
mind saying it but i don't i think
everybody likes to be have a pat on the
shoulder and say and when i started in
this game in this business i didn't stop
getting pats on the shoulder because i
was trying to overturn the system i was
the underdog
and this is repetitive of the british
culture
where build your own
oh my when your back's against the wall
it doesn't happen whether it's business
or particularly small when you're backed
against the wall you're starting you you
know you're you're the underdog you're
moving through the ranks they couldn't
support you more but when you get to the
top they want to see your father as
quickly as possible
right now that's part and parcel of i
don't have a problem with that what
drives me crazy
is that the same people from the same
social media handles
literally spend
their entire day
on my account
trolling me
like and it doesn't make me angry and it
doesn't make me want to have a tear up
with them
but it just baffles me do you mean but
you want to go around these people's
houses
and just have a chat with him not
violently
although
you know
maybe it could go that way
do you know what i mean and just say
because i want to speak to these people
i want to say what what do you do like
not in a bad way i don't want to i'm not
here to criticize you but
you you have so much
passion
and energy
to to put
me down and our stuff down imagine like
what you could achieve if you put that
if you channel that into a positive but
that
that their life is based around
giving people stick on social media you
know
that's what makes them happy sadly or
probably not happy because they're
probably not a habit but you know what i
mean that
to show their mate look what i see what
i just posted see that meme i made up i
mean look at that one i just put a
computer generated photo of him look
look
with a [__] on his head well that's
[__] hilarious but that's that's life
i suppose isn't it so i don't know i've
changed a lot over the last few years
because
i've just
you end up i'm 42 now and i feel like
the last 10 years or so
i've just
i've achieved so much in my life
particularly in my personal life which
is
you know
the most important thing for me
but
it's kind of passed me by
at the same time
and i just can't be asked
anymore to get agitated or angry with
all those pop neck either who called me
a [__] in the air after the aj i was
gonna bring that up as he was saying it
because i i
i personally like that you know you're
just seeing your guy lose you're pissed
off and there's funds
what we didn't feel like we got in the
fight from maybe the people we were
expecting yeah yeah was that sort of
yeah i'm not expecting anthony's corner
or whatever but the way you showed that
fight i was like okay this is what we
want to see someone who's pissed off and
wants to put this right and i mean the
guy did [__] himself so it was
just like
during the night i don't mind i don't
drink at the shows i don't like so i'm
sober as a judge right
you've got 70 000 people that have had a
beer
okay
so all throughout the night i'm up and
down that gantry right eddie eddie there
yeah and i try and stop and talk you
know to have a photo whatever and it was
just this
this group and i saw i walked past him
and he went eddie eddie
i went
and then just as i got out of eye shot
you [__] and it was like no mate not
now not there and i'm listening i'm
limited i can have a little bit of a go
but nothing major but at that point i
that i could have i could have taken on
12 months i was just ready to go and you
could have knocked me out clean i would
have been happy because i was just ready
to go
in actually now um i kind of feel that
this is probably a little bit deep but i
just feel like
the country and the public at the moment
feel like we're all at melting point
you know what i mean i feel like we're
at a really pivotal time in our history
you know from a social standpoint
where this is not about trolling on
twitter this is just about i think i
feel like there's so much anger
around
and i think obviously the pandemic
doesn't help you know the the economic
climate doesn't help
people laying on the m25 don't help you
know but i just feel like we're a real
pivotal moment in the country's
history where i i i i'm concerned
like for the future
of
future generations
and the future of our country because i
think people
are losing the plot not not from a you
know
a mental health point of view although
that's a major issue as well but i just
i just see anger i just come back from
after i went to the state i went to
antigua for a few days right
and it's like i don't know it's london
it's just but
you know
you sit on the beach there and you see
people finish their day at work and go
down and have a little
you know we're deadly which is a local
beer and maybe a game of qriket on a
beach and
you know
the phones are on the side
and then you land back in london
and i'm just so all i'm seeing is
miserable people all i'm saying is anger
all i'm seeing is people on their phones
or you troll they'll pick
i don't know i feel like we've lost
touch with
with reality
and i think i think most of it honestly
i think he's that
absolutely
and i say that to my kids all the time i
think it's the worst thing and i'm
listen i'm massively guilty jesus christ
i was looking at my screen time the
other day and the pickups you know you
can look at how many times you pick your
phone up it's got to stop
it's got to stop i think i don't
honestly i think i think that is the
root
of what is going on right now because
when was the last time
but what do you do when you sit
somewhere what did you used to do when
you're on a train or you're on a plane
or you're on a beach yeah or you're at a
football match
you pick your phone up don't you now but
surely that what did you used to do i
don't remember because i don't know what
to do anymore when i'm sitting on a
plane or a train and i haven't got my
phone in my hand he passed down i don't
look out the window and think about what
i'm doing i think this was about why
people may be just having those
mental
episodes where
we're not actually contemplating
life enough and because we're
distracting ourselves from the mobile
phone so much
that when people used to put their time
into family and friends and you know
like people used to be
really looking after their neighbors and
stuff like that and i feel like now it's
it's all just about trying to climb the
social ladder for most people you know
under the age of 30 especially it's all
about how many followers you've got and
what your social status is instead of
like who you actually are
as a person and the frustration that
you're talking about in society and how
unhappy people are and the pressure
people probably feel financially
it i completely agree i've never seen
our country so negative in my life
well it's in every fashion it doesn't
matter and that negativity which i talk
about online you know like even
that that is that seems to be almost its
own pandemic of
um
got that glass half empty mindset of
come on like you know and it's like
we've done a press conference today and
they said you know
when white pulled out
why didn't you just can the show
well
why don't you ask me another question to
say when white pulled out you know
well done for cracking on
and giving these fighters the
opportunity to earn money and win titles
you know i mean it's like
you can turn your life around you can
turn that mindset around so easily but
you're just infiltrated in today's world
really by negativity and like you say
people more worried about what their
life looks like
rather than what their life is really
like
you know and that that that is a
frightening thing i see it my daughter
you know my one daughter she's 12.
mate
i just it scares your life at me because
i look at it and i think
you know
why
why do you want to live your life
document your life to random pit like
and all you really care about is what is
how you're perceived
on social media right
it's a big problem big problem and uh
people don't take silly pictures anymore
eddie if it's not got a brand in in the
photo or it doesn't look like you've
spent a lot of money doing whatever
you're doing
nobody takes a goofy picture anymore
because you don't look cool you know but
but you know taking a goofy picture
anyway or taking any kind of picture and
wanting people to see it and wanting
them to comment
just creating the curie
you know
like what why would you want to what a
mad world we live in yeah
anyway no you you've literally nailed it
yeah yeah but how do we change
you know how we gonna change the mindset
of the country you know we got off the
country want to do one thing after time
you want to do another thing you know
you've got a government telling you
really what you
what you need to do or you need to do
this to be able to do this you know
you've got people gluing themselves to
the road
right on the m25 stop i mean the [__]
whole thing you've got the whole
question's gone now
you know
so we just gotta stay calm
and the way that you stay calm is just
just to stop
think spend time with people who you
care about and care about you
just
you know like i said
come off the phone
just get get inside your mind
and look after yourself and your family
but but mainly yourself because that's
how you're going to go on and achieve
success is to have a clear mind and have
an understanding
there's a great poem right and i know
you um you can edit this out a little
bit while i look for this chris chris
eubank over here no yeah yeah
i believe it was rudyard kipling who
wants it
this is
this is just the greatest greatest
poem i've ever seen i've ever heard
right okay i'm the man in the man in the
glass
when you get what you want
in your struggle for self
and the world makes you king for a day
then go to the mirror and look at
yourself
and see what that man has to say
for it isn't your father or mother or
wife
who judgment upon you must pass
the fella whose verdict counts most in
your life is the man staring back from
the glass
he's the fella to please never mind all
the rest for he's with you clear up to
the end
and you've passed your most dangerous
difficult test if the man in the glass
is your friend
you may be like jack horner a chisel a
plum
and think you're a wonderful guy
but the guy in the glass says you're
only a bum if you can't looking straight
in the eye
you can pull the whole world down the
pathway of years
and get pat's on the back as you pass
but your final reward will be heartbreak
heartache and tears if you've cheated
the man in the glass
now that is a [__] great poem it's
it's not being a man
well yeah i mean we can change that to
make sure that he can accommodate the
female race as well
of course in the modern era but it is
called man in the glass unfortunately um
but
it what that means is is
you have to be comfortable
with yourself
and that that will give you complete
sanity and clarity in what you're doing
and only that because without being
comfortable in yourself and what you're
doing
you can't overcome those those hurdles
and once you do
you're comfortable and confident in
whatever you do and you know that you
can look yourself in the eye and say i'm
a good guy i'm doing the right thing
you know i'm looking after my own i'm
you know i'm working hard i'm doing all
these things and then and then life is
sweet
as long as you do that you know you
can't do any more
so i love that poem because how many
people can do that how many people can
look themselves in the mirror and say
i'm living the right life i'm doing the
right thing i'm working hard enough i'm
chasing my dreams i'm making the most of
every day
i don't think i i mean i can sometimes i
can't all this time
it's difficult to do that and it's funny
you should
say that poem actually because in the
last few days i remember thinking to
myself like
you got lighting up on your cellmate you
know i mean like
you got to talk to yourself as if you're
your mate and it's a it's a tricky one
because the thing that drives especially
people like yourself is nothing's ever
good enough and always chasing the next
big win
but
if you don't give yourself a pat on the
back
you will basically as you're saying fly
through life and realize when you're 60
years old
[__] all i did great why didn't i
appreciate myself back then
i mean
i couldn't agree with that more and
when i'm doing you know on my podcast
i'll do it at bbc all these people i
talk to they say exactly the same thing
right frank lampard i think it was um
mark cavendish you know all these these
great athletes mo farah
i did this i won the champions league
and i stood there with a trophy and i
lifted it up
and i i didn't feel like i thought i
would feel
that's really sad
and because it's the journey
the process is what you get addicted to
rather yeah and in your head you think
when i get to the top of the mountain
but then you've got nothing left like
for you that's the thing that was
driving you you this is you know this is
a very good counseling session for me so
thank you but it is i do a show a great
you know
what a show
was it
you know wow you that must have been
amazing because
i don't you know i never once stood back
and went
[__] how good was that
you know and that's a very scary thought
that's something i'll work on more than
anything well between the liverpool show
you've just done for example yeah you
know that was [__] fantastic mate
yeah um but you know maybe it wasn't the
biggest show you've ever done by you
know any means because you've done some
gigantic shows but
that to me is exactly what boxing needs
that show had you know good size names
amazing fights a storyline everyone
could invest in it was centered around
the community uh you know if you god
imagine you could do one of those every
week you know what i mean i don't know
it's not quite right yeah but yeah but
then it's like you get in the process of
onto the next one and you know what
i know it's a good show but i bet i'll
get kicked in the nuts in a couple of
weeks
but you you are right you know that that
lightning up thing
is important because sometimes you know
i think people
i'm i'm at my best
when i'm in a good mood
you know what i mean people love to see
me
with coogan on interviews talking [__]
having a laugh doing stupid things that
end up becoming a meme you know but you
can only have that energy if you're
happy and if you if you feel good and
you're not always happy sometimes you
have to front out i'm sure you do these
sometimes i think [__] you know what
then oh my god i'll speak to that
[__]
turn you know but you have to come on
don't you hey it's so good to be talking
to you you know so
i've had depression for a few years and
that there's been a few times where i've
been like
you know i've avoided podcasts for that
reason because it is you feel like a
fake prick you know when you're putting
it on don't you but yeah but how did it
you know when you went through that
stage in your life
at what point did you realize
because i feel like with depression
that
you have you know
you have to identify that it exists
within you and it has to be a long
period of time where
you might just think you're pissed off
or you might just think your energy
levels are low and you know what i mean
and it's good now that it's okay to be
able to say you know what i think i'm
suffering from depression because i'll
tell you something now if i would have
said that to my dad 10 years ago let
alone 20 years ago he would have just he
would have had him again he was going
sword what are you talking about yeah
sort out depression pull your socks up
you know i mean that's the old school
mentality
i think i just had to realize what the
difference was between circumstantial
depression when you're going through a
rough time
and then clinical depression where it
doesn't matter what the [__] happened
throughout your day
you will feel like [__] and once i
realized okay
my life is great
and i'm still feeling like [__] and i
still feel rock bottom yeah the the
minute i went on medication and all of a
sudden i was like oh i feel
normal again or kind of normal at least
and not wanting to [__] you know do
something stupid every other day um
and that was where i realized i
basically had like a medical chemical
thing wrong with me
and
i've been much better ever since you
know but it took years before i actually
went
[__] i'll take anything i'll do anything
because i'm one of those guys who
doesn't go to the doc unless his legs
hanging off um but i'm glad i did you
know what i mean
mark cavendish said something that the
cyclist in in uh he suffered from
depression same kind of thing where just
chased his dream chased success chased
everything kept winning kept with and
nothing was ever enough and he said it
was amazing he said
um
that he would like
he would need a spoon for his coffee
and he would open the drawer and there'd
be no spoon and it was like the [__]
world has ended you know i mean he was
like where's the [__] you know and it
was only i think he said it was that
kind of incident where he just thought
to himself
what like he said and it would put him
in a bad mood for like the whole day yep
because there was no spoon he said and
just the smallest things
were making me feel like complete [__]
and and it was you know
you've got to be careful you've got to
look after yourself and it's good to see
people putting so much
focus on looking after yourself even
though we're still not doing it
really
it's a work and progress mate
um
let's talk um obviously the the aj
situation if that's all right mate what
a a night that was um
you know obviously usyk showed
how good he really is and i think i
personally predicted him to win a
decision uh before the fight because the
years just elite but once you watched it
back i'm assuming you did what was it
like for you watching it back
well frustration is a good word because
you know
the one thing i didn't want him to do in
that fight was trying out box alexander
rusik
and that was exactly what he tried to do
now was that down to stubbornness
was that down to a bit of lack of
confidence of what
he
was supposed to do or the game plan
particularly
i think a little bit of both to be
honest with you i think that
too much information
too many points of view i mean if you
look back on the fight in the ring
you know i mean aj's a very strange
cat when it comes to ring walks anyway
you know he's stopping he's going back
he's seen some lady down there she used
to cooking lunch after his training
eventually he goes over to him he gives
her a hug you know i'm walking out
thinking where's he gone what's he doing
it was a bizarre they're high fiving
stuff yeah you know and but that's not
that's not a sign of that he's not
focused or he hasn't trained he's just
you know and but when he gets in the
ring
he goes over clifford mitchell was there
who's uh runs our security he used to be
a heavyweight fighter for the british
have a great fight and he starts talking
to him about the
fight do you know what i mean what do
you think what do you think you know
and that what that tells me more than
anything is just
a lack of confidence of of the game plan
and of what i have to do if you know
categorically what you have to do
and you know that if you don't do it
you're going to be [__] told
during that one minute break between
rounds
what you've got to do anyway
you don't go searching for the answers
what i mean
the problem is sometimes with aj is he's
smart
he you can't bluff him right so you
can't go up to him and say mate yeah you
what you got to do is do this and yeah
and he goes yeah
right you know he needs to know
that
he's
got it the strategy right he's prepared
he's executed it in training repetition
when he boxed andy ruiz in a second
fight
they said to him you have to fight like
this
right wasn't his most entertaining fight
but he followed the instructions down to
a fee and won every single round when
you start searching for too much
information
things become confusing when people say
oh i just i think he's lost a little bit
of his killer instinct no what he
realized after a while is that he just
can't fight
like he does and and have a long career
and just rely on that style to be
everyone you know when he boxed glitch
though it was only braun and heart that
got him through to win that fight now
all of a sudden he goes in even when he
fights for that king you know he's
having a bit of a walk fights andy ruiz
stuns him thinks he can just walk
through him and realizes that that you
need more strings to your bow
so he starts focusing more on boxing
right which actually won him the rematch
but there's a time and play
do you know what i mean the aj that box
klitschko would have probably beaten
alexander of six that night or certainly
had a much better chance of beating it
than than the aj that turned up that
night
but it's not just about you see the you
know the man on the street says what's
he doing you gotta just get you gotta
stick it on him it's not as easy as that
and we shouldn't take away from the
brilliance of usyk and the footwork of
us because
he made aj second-guess himself too many
times in the fight
you see the way you see the way he
raises the level upstairs you know and
he
he puts he doesn't let you set your feet
but he never stopped moving so you know
if you're going from pulev who
it by comparison was a [__] statue
right you know what i mean
uh yeah he he constantly made aj have to
think
and um
i even
but the thing is with with uc um the
weight take the weight it's easy the way
to beat i mean
chisora for the first three or four
rounds did all the things that actually
is effective against right which is to
basically when you talk about not
letting someone set 126 on that back
foot and loses his own balance right
that's the time
where you you can jump all over him and
hurt him and listen usic said after the
fight for me
no oh
aj hurt him or he can punch him in
you know he i think he hit him you know
with a couple of clean shots hurt into
the body a couple of times but he never
landed a power punch aj in 12 rounds i
don't know if he threw one
yeah i don't i think you're right but
that because as well sometimes you're
overthinking to a point where i can't
throw that yet because i'm not set here
and you know he's waiting to do that no
no you back him up you make him lose his
balance and when you do you jump all
over him and you beat the [__] out
do you understand
you know and and that that's what he
needed to be told
i think absolutely not by it i think
they were too much admiring it to to too
much allow
worrying about what you sicked as well
without worrying about what aged as well
and i think part of that is
uh the stamina factor of yousek was a
concern it's like if you pull the
trigger the way you normally do
if you don't get him out of there with
that pull of the trigger with pulev you
can take a few rounds get your stamina
back pull it again
with you sick if you pull that trigger
and you miss or you don't get him out of
there there's every chance he's going to
run you out of town in the next few
rounds yeah and i felt like that made
him a little bit
tricky
yeah i think he thought about that as
well but i'd like to flip that in the
mindset and say pull the [__] trigger
and do so much damage that you can't
exactly ain't the same guy yeah like
what you didn't do uh klitschko because
even even after klitschko dropped aj
he wasn't in a position the couple he's
on it one he was tired he was hurt he
was good exactly go to maine yeah so the
same thing with uc you put enough damage
in enough by the way you know you're
getting out of there
if need be
you put i'm telling you now aj lanza's
power punch is on u6 he will get him out
of there he will damage him he will mark
him up and he will hurt
so if after six rounds you are tired and
your tank is beginning to empty make
sure that [__]
is in pain
and his legs don't work
yeah so because that was the one thing i
always thought in that fight you've got
to make a dent in this guy in the first
six rounds and he didn't make a dent in
it that was the main problem and he let
him get into the championship round
because listen after eight rounds not
however way you want to score it
everyone had it reasonably close then
uship just went 9 10 11 12. thank you
very much i won all of those and now
it's shut up it was just that didn't
they just a championship right now i
appreciate it
you know you know what the [__] you're
on about yeah yeah well so do you
actually which quite surprises me
for a youtuber um
no
i i it was it was a master class by usic
and and that's what worries me a little
bit in the rematch is i really want aj
to win i've become an even bigger fan of
his as the years have gone by and i
really
i think he's a great champion
that i think with with ruiz the plan to
get him to the win in the rematch was so
clear and straightforward but as you say
it's a lot more complicated with um a
usic who uh gave him a boxing lesson it
wasn't like uh
you know he just got clipped and never
recovered with the equilibrium like last
time i felt like this was there was
levels and and as you say there's very
few paths to victory uh versus u6 so
what makes this more important now
coming in this is the train income and
everything else now he's literally just
done a great interview shout out to uh
coug uh cougar it was a very good
interview i thoroughly enjoyed it but
some of his answers
were [__] worrying me and i wanted
him i wanted to because on the on the
one hand he was being open a bit more
aggressive we love that but on the other
hand there was a few things that he said
now one i want to read you some of the
things that you read me a poem i'll read
you some of the
ages quote um coogan asked what the plan
was
he says you'd have to ask the team
now
red flag immediate red like that worried
me i'm like well either you know what
the plan was
and you just kind of don't want to take
responsibility or you don't you still
don't know what the plan was and you're
putting the blame on them either way
both of those answers it's still bad
d i'm assuming you know more than i do
obviously but like how did you take that
answer i feel that um he wasn't
comfortable
with the game plan because i think if
you're if you're seeking information
from other people and he does that a lot
anyway by the way he likes to take in
information but too much so in that
fight where he didn't have clarity with
what he was doing
so when you talk about what was the game
plan i think if you ask him
honestly i think his answer was would be
i don't really know
you know and and but the team will feel
they had a game plan but it's the
transition from the fighter to team to
make sure that he had
put it this way they didn't go through
camp not talking about how they were
going to be alex anderson
but for some reason
that plan
aj didn't have the confidence
in that plan
you know or or or
the communication like whatever it was
yeah the truth is he didn't
exercise
it didn't box to the right plan
was that was it the wrong plan
or what did they have the right plan but
didn't manage to communicate to him in
the right way bro
you see yourself aj is a clever bloke
he's you know he he executes what you
tell him to do so if he's if he doesn't
know what the [__] plan is that's
shocking to me like especially when
you've had three months to get ready for
one of the best boxers in the world and
you're talking to clifton mitchell in
the corner what do you reckon what do
you reckon i should do seconds whereas
you sick stood looking like you're like
the terminator you better know what you
should do mate you're in there you know
he knew what he had to do that that's
the key for the rematch particularly and
if he doesn't know
what to do in the rematch but more
importantly if he doesn't have
confidence
in the game plan
then it's going to be a [__] hard
night's work okay
if he
if he is told by someone he believes in
how to win this fight
and and they practice and they practice
and they practice and they practice he
will be using in a rematch right i truly
believe that but if he doesn't get it
right
then you gotta say oh six a huge
favorite in that rematch but clearly
whether there was a game plan or not
you know i'm pretty sure there was a
game but i don't believe he had a
confidence in what he was doing or or in
that specific game plan and that is a
breakdown
of communication between fighter and
thing i think um it isn't the first time
that we've seen that with between him
and rob mccracken and this isn't me
having a go at rob mccracken uh
specifically but uh we've seen in the
ruiz fight him saying
you know what do i do like and looking
really sort of unsure of how to handle a
situation but with this one
when we're in the later rounds and aj is
clearly losing the fight and we're here
in the corner say get behind the jab
rather than take the fight to him and
rather than pull the trigger like we're
all screaming at the tv to do so and
then later again in the fight
when we are all hearing and i don't know
who said this but brilliant aj
the whole boxing community uh that that
line if you look in the comments
like is just everywhere brilliant aj
brilliant because it was such a
ludicrous thing to hear
at a point where you're clearly losing
why do you think someone is shouting
brilliant aj at that point in a fight
i think
i agree with you by the way um i heard
that too much from the corner
um if you're losing a fight or if the
fight's nip and tough i don't want to be
hearing that from the corner there were
certain things that some you know
there were too many voices in my opinion
right that not even on the night just in
general in camp right
certain people
well you know were there to make him
do certain things or he was learning
certain things so for instance the
beautiful aj might not be
always won the round it might just be a
specific thing that he has
he has learned in camp or worked on a
camp there's no excuse for it i'm not i
don't even want to attempt to justify it
the one thing i'll say
about the instruction from the corner
i feel that when you get to 10 11 12
i think there was an element perhaps
from
maybe rob mccracken that felt that his
tank was empty
right his eye was [__] and it was
quite a bad injury and probably felt
if you get behind your jab and you nick
these rounds
it may be you know if if you can win
these rounds on your jab
we got half a chance but sometimes you
look at your fighter in the corner and
no
like when he hurt his eye and he
couldn't see and he gets to 11 and 12.
he took he took a hammer in the 12
right i think maybe rob at that point
knew he cannot he doesn't have
the ability to go out here at this point
back him up and knock him out that's
what i think now yeah for me the
instruction should have come after four
rounds
not ten yes
because actually he lost i think he was
three one after four rounds or something
easily and then listen then aj had a
decent they'll run in the middle nicked
a couple of rounds but you've got to
flag it up sooner than that mate this
ain't working you haven't put a dent in
him you know where's the body shot and
getting behind a jab he's fine but back
him up with a jet you know move in with
your feet once you back him up with a
jab knock him off balance and then close
the distance cut the ring off get your
foot on the outside not on the inside
you know move to your right whatever the
instruction has got to be but
you know it was a bad night at the
office but you know
rob mccracken's more than just a trainer
to him you know he's a mentor he's he's
been an advisor and he won him you know
aj won the klitschko fight but i think
he's doing there we're not wondering
about rob mcgregor because when he went
back to that corner after the fifth
round
and the sixth round and he sat him down
and he said listen to me now that's the
voice there has to be that trust
the one boy
and you know aj's brought in different
people to work on different things
whether it's defense whether it's
footwork whether it's pad
there's got to be this is a
sport where when you're at the bottom of
the well
and there may not be many ways out the
one voice you hear
has got to be able to make things happen
for you you know what i mean and it's a
it's a tough job and i feel like
trainers get a lot of stick when a fight
goes wrong you know but but that's
that's the sport they're in but you know
i didn't like the beautiful stuff i
didn't like the beautiful stuff because
i it just if you're in there you think
it's actually after the fight
aj
must have known he lost but it wasn't
like he thought have i got you know
because you you're making a very good
point
you're losing the fight yeah yeah right
that was look at that go back to you're
blowing it down angelo dundee you know
have a little slap if you want you've
got you know but too many
i said to aj you know sometimes you've
got a great team people sometimes people
love you so much they don't want to give
you the better right some people in
certain situations and it's not really a
reflection of anything some people want
to keep their job
absolutely all right he's got more
trainers than jd supports me it's it's
the amount of people when he started
rattling off his team in that cougar
interview i was like he's like well i've
got my main guy well i've got my other
main guy i've got my other main guy i'm
like wow like do you sound ridiculous me
like but and i i i do um
know he's a sponge and he's got a thirst
for knowledge but
from what i understand he's always been
this way of like you listen to anyone
and he'll try and absorb anything he
can't clearly why you know he's still
got that mentality but at this point in
his career
i expect him on his 11th world title
fight to have more of a self-assured
like when i interviewed tyson fury he
basically was like no one could tell me
anything about boxing at this point in
my career i don't know what i mean and
i'm not saying he should be like tyson
fury i'm just saying at this stage
yeah
but two very different people part of aj
you know in his 25th fight 26th fight
with only 30 odd amateur fights
he's still learning price and fury is
not
right this this is the the best tyson's
ever going to be
but he's he's got all the knowledge he's
ever going to have he's not really
interested yeah he wants direction from
sugar hill and he wants instruction but
most of the time he's in there doing
what he knows he's got to do
aj's a different different individual
and and but once he has the confidence
and belief in what he's doing i believe
he's unbeatable
but he didn't have it that night and
it's not a case of well
forget why hasn't he got it or shouldn't
he have that let's just make sure he's
[__] got it agreed i mean that that
that's the key but with the right
instruction with the right communication
with the right belief
in that person he will have it that's
that's different and that's where where
the work goes on now and the research
goes on to make sure that next time it
don't happen again
so it
my theory in regards to the brilliant aj
and and get behind your job i think
personally i think
aj needs that positive reinforcement
that you say you respond well to the pat
on the back and i think that that might
have been just to give him as much
positivity as possible and get him out
of that fight in one piece and get them
on the rematch
um
but the the thing that you said about
trust and trusting the voice
it feels like right now aj has a lot of
loyalty and and clearly loves uh rob
mccracken uh but the trust seems to not
be there anymore and at that point you
know yes he might want to keep rob
involved and when he was asked about
this he couldn't give a straight answer
and it was it was
it didn't sound good if you're rob
mccracken listen to it or feel aj is
saying it it didn't like well i'll have
to work out if rob wants to be involved
with my next person who might teach me
and i was like difficult conversation
though
you know
it is but he was the one who decided to
have that with coogan you know he was
the one who would like so of course he's
going to ask the question
and
there's not long do you know what i mean
before the using fight so i think he
needs to make that decision quickly yeah
i think that but that's why he's being
proactive you know yeah he didn't he
didn't sit on his hand and sulk he got
on a plane he went out to america he
traveled all around the country
speaking to people looking at gyms
looking at ways to improve and i think
he should be commended for that
obviously he ain't out partying and
boozing and sulking he's out trying to
improve and trying to get himself best
prepared for the rematch
um
what the the one other thing he said in
that interview which the final thing
i'll put to you he said i had no
indication
that it wasn't going right
um
that was a bit of a shock as he said i
was touching music
uh but you know i didn't really
understand that um
do you think you should be in this
corner i mean you could just scream at
them
again when you get to a stage where you
need you need people around you
but you know i met him
two days after the fire and i sat down
and said i have to tell you honestly
this is what i think you know and i told
him my honest opinion because at the end
of the day
you ain't a mate
if you ain't telling people the truth
anyway and if someone needs your help or
or needs to find a way to improve
and you're not telling him your honest
opinion and it was you know all those
people have been sat down individually
really as a not not for a telling off
just for a chat and
it's when you sit down with them after a
defeat where people start coming out
saying yeah well actually
this and this and this and this well you
didn't say that you know when you're
winning no one says anything do they
so but you have to have people around
you and listen he's got a lot of people
around him that care
but the ones that care enough to stand
up and say mate
i i'm you know maybe i'm going to walk
away if this doesn't change because i
don't believe in it
do you know what i mean i don't believe
in the setup or
this process
in camp
so
i'm out
but no one really does that do they
because one it's a huge opportunity to
be an anti-joshua's camp
you know for three two you're gonna
might be making a lot of money
and you're involved in massive nights
but
um a lot of people saying he's got too
many yes men around him
i think he's got a lot of people that
care for him to be honest with you and
and he's a he's an unbelievable loyal
likable guy but sometimes
the truth hurts and you've got to be
honest with people and you've got like
what you've said there is spot on you
know where was the person saying to him
after four or five rounds mate you're
gonna blow this unless you do this
where was you know
where was it do you want to lose your
world heavyweight titles tonight yeah
unless you know if you don't
do this now yeah yeah
and that's easy to say isn't it part
on a podcast but
a lot of a lot of it should be a
formality yeah well you're you're
risking your world title by not pulling
the trigger and when he says in the
podcast you know his interview
um i watched you know fury versus wilder
and they were blowing out their ass by
round three it's like yeah but they were
trying to kill each other you you
weren't trying to kill you sick you were
you weren't you know what i mean you
just weren't so
that's heavyweight boxing when you're
trying to rip each other's head off it
will just
it will be who wants it more you know
what i mean and i think
it really didn't reflect well on aj when
those two went to war the way they did
and he gave his belt up without a fight
in my opinion without the fight that he
gave
uh klitschko or dillian white or you
know because we know he's got the dog in
him and that that ain't really my
uh the dog is not what i'm sort of
worried about it's just him having that
person he trusts i think that's what he
um and we've seen like like you you grew
up around uh great fighters like lennox
lewis who changed trainers and it just
revolutionized uh them and tyson fury's
done that with cronk it's a shame
because i think cronk would be perfect
for his yeah literally you never know
you never know fury come out and fury
said i'll i'll train him i'll tell him
how to be and then aj said yeah why not
and then
but i'm thinking because aj's box billy
and white maybe they can sort of train
each other for those
fights you know we'll see what happens
well the the white fury fight uh will be
really exciting too yeah i think
currently
i see too many people saying why would
he fight dillian white you know he
should i thought wait he said one that
one is the mandatory challenger yeah two
it's an old british heavyweight world
title fight that's really a [__] a
lot of fun
that's a great fight great fight so
hopefully we get that next as well
um where do you think
the the heavyweight landscape now has
changed like so much and i feel like
it's hard because wilder and fury have
been tied up together and then we've had
aj who's lost two fights in his last
four uh but dillian wade has just been
getting on with business but then he did
get knocked out as well like it's very
difficult to rank these guys but do you
have a
what order do you think would be fair
right now
um difficult because publicly it's hard
to not say fury because people just
think i'm not saying fury for the sake
of it you know i thought fury's last
fight was thrilling
but if i'm critical
he's beaten one guy in the last
nearly three years right and that's not
his fault by the way but i don't see how
you can keep moving up the pound for
pounding this by just beating the same
guy but it
did regardless of how thrilling it was
for me i believe
that aj was the best heavyweight in the
world now is he still the best
heavyweight in the world he's got a
point to prove but if who's six beating
him and who's six pound for pound number
two in the sport
how is he not number one heavyweight in
the world i mean i don't know but
yeah it's hard it's hard to split those
guys right now you know tyson fury
i think beats alexander rusik i do
because of the side because of the
movement i i think he i think he's a
great fighter it might not be the most
interesting fight to watch but you know
but
i i think if you're going to be
you know
i believe aj can beat him all but if you
want to rank them now
on paper
as of today
then i think you have to do one and two
usick and fury you know and three aj and
four
silly and white
and five you're dion you know five
beyonce wilder you've got you know
wilder
wilder's gonna be in some fun fights you
know he's not
i want to say he's not very good people
go mad at me but he's not very good like
but he [__] hits like a mule you know
so and he's really entertaining but he's
not very good
um but he can still beat everyone
absolutely that's the amazing thing
about me
i think everyone is going to outbox
deontay wilder and most people can beat
him but if they get chin he will win
and that's what's so exciting
it's a tricky one with the u6 thing if
if aj beats yousek
does yusik get a rematch
no contractually no
would you be inclined to give him a
rematch
depends on a number of things i mean
depends on what happens in that second
fight depends on the value for the
rematch the demand for the rematch
depends on whether the fury fight is
available
uh for the undisputed or a silly and
white beach fury and then you can do an
undisputed fight you know i mean i just
feel like right now i just want to win
the rematch you know yeah after that you
kind of worry but a lot of people said
you know when he beat andy reid
surely you've got to give andy marie the
rematch we're like [__] off we've done
that one now now we're moving on and
doing this do you not think that sort of
um
not what's best for boxing though in
regards to
legacy and stuff because they want a
piece now when the one that ruiz
was brutal after that after that ruiz ii
fight which was a decent fight wasn't
overly entertaining but aj won every
single round it wasn't like they were
calling through through the roofs for
number three but if they were by the way
and saudi came back or whoever came back
and said right we're putting up a load
of money again to do number three we're
doing number three
and the same with the usic fight you
know if it's a brilliant fight and
everyone wants to see number three and
and you know then we do it
but right now all i'm thinking about is
be using and try and get back in the
line for undisputed yeah but i i feel
that in the division right now i just
think we might be approaching a merry go
round of aj
fury white you know aj fury usyk white
wilder ruiz i i you know like all these
guys can beat all these guys
so that's really exciting let's just see
the best fights in the division well the
last time i support you you were in the
process of finishing up the contract
with sky you've now moved with dezorn
and i've heard um i don't know i think
it might been tony bellew who said you
have a vision
to grow much room and i just wondered
like
what that vision is and how and what
sort of stepping stones do you plan to
get in order to get to that point the
only place for us to go
from here is
more domination in global markets and
eventually quite frankly a float you
know i mean that's
we're at that size now where all the
approaches are coming in from you know
major investment funds and and people
saying look we we want to be part of
this journey it's a very unique business
you know not just across boxing but you
know the pdc with the darts world
snooker you know the poor gold across so
many different sports
my plan with with boxing
is to globalize the business and the
sport in what we're doing right now we
are the only promoter that is promoting
globally
even internationally quite frankly you
know the american promoters aren't
promoting in the uk they might do one
show
as a one-off we're doing 46 shows in
across various different markets
including the uk us mexico italy spain
france uzbekistan saudi arabia australia
i mean it's just
what we're doing is quite phenomenal but
we need to put this network together of
what we're doing ufc i'm so envious of
and i always say to our guys watch what
they're doing they have a global
business and brand that enables them to
go into new territories new markets with
brand that presence and brand profile
and hit the floor running with localized
events we've built that via mattress so
when we go into barcelona now you've got
fight fans there that follow me that
follow matram as a company that follow
our events in america aj dillian white
katie taylor devin haynie you know
sandor martin uh julio cesar martinez
destroyed
our global fighters and you create a
global network of fights good example
was our biggest spanish fire to sandor
martin just goes over and beats mikey
garcia right a couple of weeks ago
massive shock no one saw it coming but
for our spanish business
that takes boxing in that territory
through the roof and the only people
that we could expand at this rate with
globally and that the only people that
shared our vision were the zones who
have a global network for boxes
and rather than sell your individual tv
rights
to a hundred different broadcasters
around the world which you do
it's so much clearer the process and
strategy for us to do that across
one platform with design
so you know i always i always say one
sport one platform that's not their
slogan that's my slogan wherever
wherever i go in the world
i can pump that messaging you watch our
events only on the zone
and i felt that in the uk market we got
to a point where
there's a difference between an anthony
joshua pay-per-view
and
a chizzora parker pay-per-view or a
dillian white povetkin paper tip these
are the fight nights where we got so
much criticism over the years
for staging them as pay-per-view events
the reason being is because the tv
rights
money wasn't there from the broadcaster
to be able to stage that fight as a
normal saturday night fight night
with the zone we can run those
pay-per-view events as non-pay-per-view
as part of a much cheaper subscription
model
now people recently kicked up a bus when
you know the zone said we may have to
introduce that functionality may
for certain one-off events anthony
joshua has become a free network agent
in the uk
you cannot stage an anthony joshua usyk
rematch as part of that cheap
subscription model that the zone is
offering
but what you can do is take fights that
are perceived to be
not pay-per-view
off that model because we were doing too
many pay-per-view events and to be
honest with you it was draining the life
out of me having to have that continued
argument with the fight van where he
said it's not pay-per-view and i would
say it is and everyone will see the
pants up
and you will see those pay-per-view
numbers falling because in this market
in this climate
people are not
prepared to keep paying
20 pounds 24 pounds 99 for one off night
and i just felt that this model enabled
us to make bigger fight could it smith
val is a great example
he goes to both those guys neither of
those guys really want to take that
fight you know in the position they're
in unless the money's right
you know pay the money
well now we can do it and we get those
fights like that you know and that's
we're only three months in this disney
uk project project but you're gonna see
fights like that happen it's just normal
saturday night fight night now i know
dillian's out this weekend but dillian
white against otto wallin
is a 20 pound pay-per-view on sky
chazora parker rematch would have been a
20 pound pay-per-view on sky it's now
part of your monthly subscription on the
zone we need more of those key temp
moments
to deliver for fight fans and now you're
getting tier timo lopez against uh
cambodia's devin haney against jojo diaz
gennady golovkin against morata you know
jamie munguir against rosado but all of
these events globally it's a it's a
brilliant product and this is just the
beginning
for the process
yeah i i know there's some teeth and
problems like obviously when i use the
app i'm like oh this could be like this
this could be like that but i
i
you guys are way ahead of the game
um
but i'm not sure the game has changed
yet is is my current
feel on it you know what i mean it's in
the right direction
sky or
they're just the old man brand don't
they they don't really get it you know
what i mean um and they so they're a
great platform i think i think it's
difficult after three months to sit
there and say we have revolutionized the
sport i mean we've had a good start
one bit of bad news with dillian white
but i feel like the production team you
know whether you like laura woods and
maya and belle you and mike costello is
different crazy to what anyone's doing
absolutely different gravy but we have
to make the fight one disappointment
that some people have voiced is paulie
malignaggi not being on the commentary
he is viewed as one of the best and you
guys obviously went in a different
direction
a little bit disappointing any reason
why
um i think he was i saw an interview the
other day where he said it was something
to do with uh four old frank smith who
works for me and start an altercation
about i don't think so i think he had
his problems
um corporately with showtime i can't
remember what happened yeah certainly
there was some controversy there that
would put a major corporation off of
using him as a broadcaster because it
certainly put show time off using him i
think paulie's brilliant i think he's a
great great commentator we've kind of
got our own our own paulie man and rg
and tony bellion a little bit you know i
don't think we can have too many
outspoken got one scouter and one new
yorker one new york italian italian giza
you know but i i think paulie's a
brilliant brilliant company
yeah i mean i'm glad you've got tony i
absolutely love the guy um and you know
i think the the flack that people gave
uh for um
the the the the female presenter you
hired sorry what's on him
um yeah who is a great presenter and uh
they too present not to break down the
fights uh but i know but it was
ridiculous
yeah it's like you know she doesn't know
anything about boxing i know
but you know yeah she's been to some
fight she's entertaining yeah she's a
huge name yeah she has a huge social
media following you know she
it's bringing something completely
different in the sport now if we add
maya drama breaking down fight i agree
with you ridiculous but we don't she
cuts it out with tony she goes to laura
woods who is outstanding as well who
goes to mike costello and andy lee
brilliant you know you've got darren
barker and chris lloyd the analytical
team breaking up the early play it's
really really good just the beginning
right are you are you concerned because
obviously you're going for the
international market that it might be
it's it's very english heavy there's a
lot of like people who work on talk
sport in there and you know don't get me
wrong for me that's great but
um do you think you may get in some
people from outside in america yeah i
think i mean when you look at the us
broadcast team it's different you know
you've got kate abdo sometimes with todd
grisham you've got akan barak over there
as well and you've got you've got tony
over here um did you see the the stick
that kate abdul got from bob arum oh
wow
can you believe that you know by the way
she's she's got her ear piece in and
she's first saying to her to her
head-to-head she's not you know but this
is
an 89 year old bloke who is just so
stuck in his i mean you know he's
outrageous if he don't care when you get
to 89 don't care what you say he doesn't
apologize really no no but she's very i
felt sorry for her because like you know
you're between two giants who want to
get the hell out of each other i don't
know why
you know with all due respect i
she did a great job but
putting
a woman in that situation between these
two men who want to kill each other
yeah it's a difficult thing to do and
she i thought she did great so when he's
like [__] that girl i'm like what the
hell are you talking about bro you do it
like
i don't know
right but listen you get you know my job
dana watch you get in between the
fighters right you bring them together
and i'm not saying that if wilder and
fury start having
a roll around i'm going to really get
get in there and start getting involved
yeah but at least i can i'm six foot
five and i can get in the middle maybe
pop one on the chin on the way you know
what i mean people would love to see
that anyway
you can't expect a dainty female
presenter to start breaking you know
breaking up i mean she could get rolled
over but that's not good i mean anything
you know
and you know bob should know better than
that and he she's only doing her job
so you know but
absolutely going back to the zone thing
though like you were talking about
taking an investment from much room and
i've seen how the ufc obviously expanded
and went to but they were bought by wma
they then launched they've launched ufc
fight pass so they now have their own
their own subscription service and
they're on network television and i'm
you know i know you're a student of
everything and you know i was wondering
if you could ever see a deer where much
room have their own thing and then the
rest oh we we do we do just launched
recently
you know i mean that's our own almost
like our own otp platform for territory
is where you don't have major tv deals
and it enables you to show that growth
and look at that growth the smartest
thing that the zone have done with with
the boxing model is it enables them to
almost gather free data and research
about territories that that have
potential for for bigger growth so
people don't realize there's only a huge
sporting sports streaming powerhouse
they're not a boxing platform you know
they're in italy with serie r you know
they're in spain with major rights
they're in japan they're in canada with
major u.s sport as well boxing is a very
small part of what they do it's a big
part of what they do but
they're a sports streaming giant but
what the boxing model enables them to do
is to go into territory gain subscribers
gain data understand the markets before
they go in and obtain
other sporting right of course in time
they're going to pick up
many other sporting rights in the uk as
they grow their subscriber base but this
is a a great entry vehicle into these
markets for them that enables them to
particularly grow the brand right
because in a lot of these territories
like when we went into the us with the
zone it was a standing start no one had
heard of the zone in america really as a
sports viewer no one had really heard of
much of matram locally smart things on
tv on one fight a year and we went in
there off a standing start and and
really in the uk market the same thing
you know they've come in as a new
broadcaster of course they've been
disruptive but they're a brilliant
addition to the boxing roster and i
think i'm unrivalled value for money
across america uk and again just a
couple of months in in the uk so long
way to go do you uh are you the one who
gets to sort of do the creative like in
regards to the shows like is there a
creative director from the zone or is it
a mushroom guy who decides well one one
thing that was so important with the
deal was we wanted to
control the production
because i felt like you build a
narrative you build a storyline of a
show and how you want it to play out and
then you get to fight dave and you just
pass it over to a broadcaster now the
zone still have input into that
production but ultimately we're putting
the talent together we're putting the
staging together we're putting the
lighting together we're putting the
walk-on together so we can really have
that cradle-to-grave mindset of full
delivery um
but these are bright people no i mean
no i thought we were we were good these
people have calls about calls i mean
every five minutes there's another
management call meeting design call
production call
strategy calls and these people are
really bright really bright they know
exactly what they're doing they know
they know
where the future lies and that's why we
made the move we you know been a massive
opportunity uh with skylar been a great
partner we got offered a huge deal and
we chose to leave because we felt this
was the future and i'm i'm i'm
absolutely certain we're right have you
ever thought about doing a matchroom uh
belt almost like create your own
divisions create your own championships
because i only say this because one of
the difficult things for
casual fans and i'm kind of a casual fan
at this point i think um
is when you have these random fights
within it within a night where it's the
lesser-known guys it
what you're talking about is
storytelling and that's kind of your job
but obviously where are fighters came
from where they're going and on so many
fights i feel like when i'm used to the
ufc style of here is his ranking if he
wins this he'll probably fight this guy
and that's the they're great at doing
that they get you all right okay so this
all i get the story boom it's there
and i often feel like
that's part of the challenge that you
guys have because there's so many
[__] belts whereas if you just kind
of went you know what it is we've got
plenty money we've got plenty of
fighters [__] it let's just have our own
and then
that way
the pres i know nobody's not call it the
matchroom belt here and people might
think i'm crazy but like as a product it
potentially could make things a bit more
straightforward for the viewer
i think it's something that in time can
work the main issue is
is the notoriety and history and the
legacy of those belts
so every young fighter wants to win
a wbc belt because they saw sugar ray
leonard beat roberto durant to win it
you know they want her ibf belt because
it was the first one they banned the
holyfield one jo domain so i don't know
i mean look you'd have to take that
plunge
i know i think it's bollocks personally
because like when a ufc heavyweight
champion it's all not heavyweight belt
it you know it they what they're 20
years old there's there's really not a
lot of history there and yeah but
that's why you know to win a ufc bill
is everything but at the moment in
boxing to win a wbc bill
is everything to that person and if you
lose the opportunity to do that it's a
long game it's a long game you know
you ain't going to bring something like
that in and every fighter goes this is
tremendous i don't care about the wbc
i've got a matching belt or i've got an
mb whatever you've got the money if
you've got the money to make it happen
and as you've just said with liverpool
if you've got the money then all of a
sudden it does matter
i think so but i respect the co you know
part of me wants to see my fighters lift
those belts as well probably maybe
because i'm a little bit of an anorak do
you mean but i know
i think what you're saying is achievable
and it's something that over time will
definitely work i've got lots of ideas
eddie i've got me i'm here all week i
mean yeah good let's not do it on the
podcast
before we go i've got to touch on one
last thing obviously um you were talking
about the pay-per-view model and how de
zone got a lot of people in interested
in america
one of the main ways they did that was
through my mates the paul brothers on
ksi
um you kind of take took a step back
showtime of then taking a step in
um before we get into the paul brothers
and what they've done recently the rumor
is mike tyson logan paul
february 2022 now
i don't think this is going to happen
but
what do you make of that just as a
possibility
i i prefer that i can't believe i'm
gonna have any debate but i prefer that
to floyd and logan thought that was
absolutely a load of bollocks
i thought what you got a pound per pound
great
against a bloke that is i mean you know
not not can't fight but like
you know
it was it was horrible horrible to watch
tyler said that it shouldn't happen but
at least like i would i would at least
want to find out what happened in that
fight all right yeah i hold my hands up
now when we go to jake
and what he's doing
he's very different
you know jake he's not fighting any real
boxers yet but he's still fighting
fighters
right he's fighting mma guys he's
fighting guys that know how to hold
their hands up
i don't mind what jake's doing i think
he's working hard i think he's a great
promoter
and i think he's putting the timing in
the gym and i think he's entitled
to have a crack
i don't like
fighters moaning like you want to davis
the other day you know these guys
shouldn't be allowed to come in and earn
this kind of money because these other
guys that i know in my gym have been
grinding for years maybe don't work like
that it's called value
is called you know worth of a product
entertainment someone's prepared of
course if someone's prepared to pay x
and someone's prepared to play x that is
the value of that fight and jake paul
and those guys have built up the
following that has enabled them to do
quite frankly whatever they want and get
eyeballs and make money
now
i don't mind jake jake he's a very good
self-promoter
he ain't he's not terrible as well by
the way like he's not you know there's a
lot of fighters out there worse than
jake paul he's not going to go and start
beating boxers that are any good
but at the same time he's putting the
timing he's doing the hard spots and
he's going out and he's performing you
know so i have no problem with what he's
doing at all
my worry and the reason i step back a
little bit is i don't want this to
become the norm
to be honest with you that's what scares
me about the whole thing and it's not
about protecting my business it's just
something that i'm very passionate about
something that i feel very strongly
about
but i did ksi against logan paul you
know like wow
an education you know just i learned so
much from that event um
it was a bit awkward for me at some of
the press conferences and stuff like
that but i knew what i was doing it
worked the numbers were great
it's just not something that i want to
do you know
all the time would i do it again
probably if it was something that my
broadcast partner really wanted me to do
in the right situation the right
scenario am i actively looking to do
stuff like that absolutely not you know
but at the same time i'm not an idiot
and i know that the whole business is
built around numbers and and built
around subscription and and for some
people pay-per-view and eyeballs and and
when someone delivers it
they deliver it and jake paul delivers
it
have you got a prediction for jake paul
versus tommy fury i don't know i mean
tommy
i mean i don't really know i've really
watched a lot of tommy i watched his
last fight
on the jake paul pod i mean
you'd like to say jake can't beat
a boxer with any ability but i just
haven't seen enough of tommy fury you
know but um
he obviously believes he can win that
fight otherwise he wouldn't take it if
he has taken out i don't know but he
he's not going to get beat at this stage
he wants listen he's going to be milking
this for
you know a nice a nice few futures so
yeah whoever he fights they will be very
confident they will be what i mean so i
i don't know how good tommy fury is but
if he gets beat by jake paul the answer
is not very good
well i spoke to big john recently and he
was very confident in his son so
that alone makes it absolutely
devastated if if tommy fury don't beat
jake paul they would be devastated
because he'd be so embarrassed yeah i
mean for someone that's supposed to be
supposed to be a prospect really you
know but
one final question mate i've seen um on
twitter it was trending uh who was the
fighter who made you love boxing and i
wondered who was the fighter who made
you love boxing
probably i know it's a bit boring but
probably mike tyson i mean
growing up i was sort of as i got into
the sport sugar ray leonard hearns
hagler duran those kind of fighters were
i mean leonard was a hero of mine i love
duran as well
um
but probably tyson going through that
area that era sorry you know when he
beat sphinx speak colder truth williams
i was actually at that fight atlantic
city last week
80 seconds or something like that um
i'm so jealous other fighters other
fighters that some people might not have
heard of but now with the car yeah and a
fighter called meldrick taylor who was
one of my favorite fighters um
he actually
got stopped by julio cesar chavez who
watched that fight with about three
seconds to go in the fight and we were
winning the fight about to
have an all-time great victory and he
was a great fighter uh of mine he's a
lot watching nigel ben of course now
connor his boy is absolutely flying um
he looks a real fighter to me like i'm
impressed with him when he first started
he was wild and he was all over the
place but he is now he's a real fighter
he's a star as well he's a star
yeah he's got he's because i'm i'm
obviously looking now at who you're
going to build this business around and
connor ben seems like a good a good
person uh one of them at least anyway
because yeah he's got the look he's got
the charisma he can he hits hard it's
it's just he's in a [__] hell of a
division isn't he
well thank you very much eddie for the
time mate uh i'm i'm looking forward to
seeing everything you do
and
yeah i i love chopping it up with you
and i think you're doing great things so
thanks for the honesty man appreciate
that mate keep up the good work and
we'll catch you soon absolutely uh that
was eddie hearn don't forget to check
his podcast out check everything that
the zone are doing it's fantastic up you
can you know you know how to get it it's
on playstation sony tv and we will be
with you very soon on the true joy
youtube channel with another pain game
podcast